HUD sucker Industries a large
corporation from New York is in the
middle of their annual meeting where a
staff member informs the directors about
their outstanding achievements including
record-breaking sales and a skyrocketing
stock price this is excellent news for
everyone but for some reason the
president's warring HUD sucker is a bit
upset in a drastic turn of events he
takes a final puff of his cigar and
commits the unthinkable from his window
surprisingly despite this tragic
accident the vice president of the
company Sydney J Musburger remains
undeterred he takes charge of the
meeting and shifts the board's Focus to
the consequences they are about to face
Sydney mentions that warring's 51 share
is scheduled to be sold to the public
within one month the board's preference
is to purchase the stock and maintain
control of the company but they lack the
financial means to do so this is because
the stock prices are very high due to
the recent success of the company as a
result Sydney devises a plan they will
have to reduce the stock price and make
it more affordable for this plans to
hire an inexperienced guy as the manager
and make him do everything wrong
elsewhere we are introduced to our
protagonist Norville Barnes who is a
recent graduate in business he arrives
in New York City with the intention of
finding a job and earning a lot of money
Norville believes that he has the
cunningness and tenacity to become a
manager but to his dismay all the jobs
reject him because they require five
years of experience disheartened he
walks away and enters a coffee shop
while having his drink he looks at the
newspaper and learns about a thriving
Corporation Called HUD sucker Industries
this gives him a glimmer of hope so he
heads towards the said location in the
next scene Norville arrives at HUD
sucker Industries and gets himself hired
as a mail room clerk the department is
overwhelmed with hectic responsibilities
and pays very little but Norville has no
choice but to accept it shortly
afterward an elderly staff member brings
a confidential and highly important blue
letter to the mail room it was sent by
none other than Warner right before his
demise the other early man instructs
Norville to deliver the letter directly
to the top level when the other male
boys see this they get scared and run
away it turns out they are all scared of
the blue letter as it is of the utmost
importance Norville reluctantly agrees
and proceeds to the elevator but even
there the other employees stare at him
in disbelief they think that he is going
to be massacred today after a while
norvel finally reaches the top and makes
his way to Sydney's office but
shockingly instead of delivering the
letter he presents a paper with a simple
Circle drawn on it claiming it to be his
latest invention however he fails to
explain the specifics of it Matthew
McConaughey would say it's a depiction
of time this leads Sydney to think that
Norville is a fool so he selects him as
a proxy for HUD sucker but Norville who
is nervous commits a series of mistakes
he accidentally sets fire to the first
page of an important document and breaks
a window causing the remaining pages of
the contract to fly away witnessing this
chaos Sydney rushes to catch the crucial
papers and finds himself dangerously
close to falling out the window himself
fortunately Norville manages to grab his
legs in the nick of time saving his life
in the aftermath of these events we see
Norville with a shave and a new wardrobe
taken a seat as the new chairman of Hud
sucker Industries his stupidity has got
him the most prestigious job in town in
the next scene an editor at the
Manhattan Argus newspaper becomes
suspicious of the decision to place an
inexperienced individual in charge of
such a prominent company in order to
find out the actual truth he sends a
talented and prize-winning reporter
named Amy Archer to investigate Norville
and uncover his true character later
that day Amy approaches Norville
disguising herself as a jobless woman
she lists down all of her qualifications
and requests he give her a job
unfortunately Norville doesn't pay her
any attention so she resorts to plan B
Amy pretends to faint leaving him with
no choice but to take her to his office
after she gets up she pretends to be
from his hometown and even lies that she
knows some of his friends surprisingly
this impresses Norville and he
immediately hires her as his personal
secretary dumb or smart nepotistic
connections will always be the way
following this Amy returns to the
newspaper office and crafts her story on
Norville portraying him as an imbecile
this causes the stock price to plummet
just as the board members wanted when
Norville reads the news article he
becomes furious at how he's depicted
unaware of the truth he instructs his
newly appointed secretary to compose a
response to the article's author he also
assumes that the author is an
unattractive elderly woman since her
picture is not included alongside her
byline hearing this Amy becomes enraged
but she controls her feelings and simply
says yes boss on the same evening she
covertly infiltrates HUD sucker
Industries in hopes of uncovering clues
about the newly appointed chairman Amy
makes her way to the top floor which is
located just behind a massive clock
there she encounters Moses a longtime
operator of the clock tower he appears
to know everything about HUD sucker and
even recognizes Amy as an undercover
reporter nevertheless he divulges that
he details about Sydney's scheme
including the deliberate manipulation of
the stock price for future acquisition
after gathering this valuable
information Amy brings the story to her
editor-in-chief she wants to publish
this story ASAP however due to the lack
of concrete evidence her boss doesn't
believe her at all the scene then shifts
to the company's annual Christmas party
where Norville finds himself among
important people a short while later
Sydney summons him and introduces him to
the other stockholders while interacting
with a finished stockholder Norville
attempts to Converse in their language
but unfortunately he ends up offending
them resulting in A Hard Punch to his
face later on Amy finds Norville on a
balcony nursing his injury she feels
slightly bad for him and tends to his
wounds after having a brief conversation
Amy realizes that Norvell is a
Brilliance and kind-hearted person who
is completely naive when it comes to
corporate politics this realization
makes her feel guilty for hiding her
true identity and betraying him Amy
attempts to confess but struggles to
summon the courage to do So eventually
there interaction takes a romantic turn
and they end up kissing passionately
Huds sucking their faces off in the next
scene president Norville decides to
launch a new product based on his Circle
concept he presents a demonstration to
the board of directors but even this
time he cannot express himself properly
this leaves the board of directors
baffled but Sydney has other plans he
believes that the product will drive
down the stock price even further so he
manipulates his associates to approve it
following this the product undergoes
various testing procedures before
reaching its final form ultimately it is
named as the hula hoop and is released
for distribution in stores in the
initial days the product experiences
complete failure due to its obscurity
resulting in stores reducing its price
day by day despite these efforts the
product remains unsold leading store
owners to eventually discard the items
on the streets offering them for free
one day a child discovers the hula hoop
and starts playing with it innocently he
puts it around his waist and swings it
in a proper manner just like Norville
had affected surprisingly this catches
the attention of several other children
who quickly rushed to nearby stores to
purchase their own sparking the
beginning of sales over time the product
gains popularity becoming a beloved toy
not only for children but also for nerds
the hula hoop disrupts the market
attracting media attention and
interviews with Norville he even
receives a congratulatory call from the
nation's president commending his
ingenious idea I was gonna play golf
today but now I'm gonna hoop Instead
This immense success results in
substantial profits for HUD sucker
Industries causing the stock price to
soar to unprecedented levels
unfortunately this spells trouble for
the board members who had sold off a
majority of their shares assuming they
could later buy them back at a lower
price as success grows Norville becomes
arrogant and indifferent just like a
typical businessman one day Amy
confronts him in a fit of anger
expressing her disappointment with his
decision to dismiss 80 percent of the
workforce she appears to have fallen in
love with him and asks him to rehire the
people again however norvel blunt
ignores her saying I can do whatever I
want hearing this Amy bursts out in Rage
and resigns from her position Norville
doesn't even try stopping her after a
while an elevator operator excitedly
approaches him claiming that he has a
new invention he brings out his product
which he calls the bent straw but
Norville just fires his ass without
letting him explain himself later that
night a janitor at HUD sucker named
Aloysius finds out about Amy's true
identity and promptly informs Sydney who
in turn reveals it to Norville the vice
president reveals that Amy has written a
news article against Norville and
despite their efforts The Argus
newspaper is eager to publish it adding
to the predicament the elevator operator
who was fired earlier now claims that
Norville stole the hula hoop idea from
him Sydney highlights norville's
mistakes and shares a saying a
businessman should never hire a prisoner
and should not offer Second Chances he
asserts that Norville despite
experiencing a brief Ascent is destined
for a steep fall suggesting that he will
soon position from HUD sucker Industries
however it is revealed that this is all
part of the board member's scheme to
oust Norville from the company moreover
they hire a psychiatrist who declares
Norville is mentally unstable and
recommends sending him to the local
psych Hospital the board of directors
believe that news of Norville being
confined to a mental institution will
undoubtedly lower the stock price
allowing them to regain control of the
company thinking that all hope is lost
Norville heads to a bar and starts
drowning his sorrows in alcohol a few
moments later Amy approaches him and
expresses her remorse for betraying him
she pleads for a second chance to make
amends but Norville walks away with a
heavy heart Shattered by the Betrayal
later he heads to the top of the
building and has a deep thought about
his life but in a tragic turn of events
his footing slips leaving him hanging
perilously Aloysius notices him in the
situation but he only watches coldly as
Norville loses his grip and plummets off
the building during his Free Fall Moses
wedges a broom handle into the mechanism
of the clock which surprisingly freezes
time and suspends Norville mid-air just
then warring HUD sucker appears in front
of him as a Divine being urging him to
read the blue letter which was supposed
to be delivered to Sydney the letter
happens to still be a norville's pocket
so he retrieves it he then reads the
letter which unveils the truth that
warring despite his apparent success was
never truly happy because he had Once
Driven away the woman he deeply cared
for furthermore the letter reveals that
warring intended for his shares to pass
to his immediate successor as president
rather than being sold to the public
this decision was made to allow the new
president to operate the company without
interference from other stockholders the
successor would have been Sydney but
unaware of this he proceeded with his
scheme to install Norville as president
in the midst of all of this Aloysius
investigates for the reason why Norville
hasn't fallen yet he spots Moses
downstairs and the two get into a fight
during their scuffle the broom dislodges
from the clock mechanism causing
Norville to resume his fall but Moses
acts quickly and delivers a powerful
punch to Aloysius causing his Dentures
to fly into the clock once again halting
its movement as a result Norville comes
to a halt just two feet above the ground
and once the clock resumes he safely
lands on the ground and rushes to the
bar there he shares his Newfound
happiness with Amy and the two
eventually reconcile following day
Norville hands the blue letter to Sydney
upon discovering that he could have
gained all the shares for free Sydney
goes mental as a result he is sent to a
sanitarium for treatment in the final
scene norvel unveils his latest
invention another enigmatic circle on a
folded sheet of paper which turns out to
be a frisbee subscribe for more videos
like this turn on the notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching